if i were to come over to your place and
say name this molecule the first thing
you would do is you would say well look
we have a double bond so we're dealing
with an alkene we have four carbons in
the longest chain there's actually one
chain here so it's one two three four
carbons so the prefix will be butte and
regardless of which end you count from
the double bond starts at the number two
carbon so this is but
but
tuine
but tui and i'd say well that's that's
very good and that is correct based on
everything we've learned but what about
what about this molecule what about the
molecule that looks like this
the molecule that looks
like
this and you'd go through the same
process you'd say it has a double bond
it's an alkene our longest chain has
four carbons one two three four
regardless of which end you start
counting from the
the double bond starts at the number two
carbon one
two three four so once again you say hey
sal that's also butte
butte
twin
and then i'd point out that these are
each fundamentally different molecules
and the reason why they're fundamentally
different molecules is because this
double bond can't rotate it's got that
pi bond there for that second bond that
keeps this carbon-carbon bond rigid so
it's not like the molecule can switch
configurations between
this
or it's not like it can switch
conformations between this and that it
cannot rotate around this double bond so
these are different molecules these are
different molecules
different molecules that will behave
different chemically
and because they behave different we
have to have different names for them
now there's two different naming
conventions one is kind of
i guess
the simpler naming convention and it
works when we have one functional group
on each of the carbons in the double
bond and then in the next few videos
we'll talk about the slightly more
advanced naming scheme that will work
when we have more than one functional
group so the first way to name it is if
you have your functional group so let me
circle the functional group so in this
top one
our functional groups
are on opposite sides
they're apart they're on opposite sides
of the carbon-carbon double bond this is
on the top this is on the bottom in this
molecule right here our functional
groups are on the same side so when our
functional groups are on different sides
we could call it trans
we could call it trans literally for i
believe latin for apart or latin for
opposite i'm not a latin scholar so
forgive me but we the the functional
groups are part so we call it
transbute tuine the other convention the
other convention to use comes from
the german four part and there we call
it enkagen and instead of writing out
enkagan we write e
in parentheses so we would call them
just a different color since this
molecule down here is blue so we would
call this
e
e button
these mean the same thing
e button but this is now kind of the
standard convention we'll see this
notation where you use ant again or e is
actually more powerful it can extend to
when we have more than one functional
group on each carbon so let me just make
it clear that the e stands for end
and
which is german for
german for
apart
or at least i believe it is i can't
speak german so i'll just have to take
people's words for it now in this
situation where our functional groups
are on the same side you could call this
cis
cisbutuen cis i believe comes from the
latin for together or
or you could call it z
or you could call it z butte tuain
bute
tuine and you could imagine this comes
this z comes from the german for
together and it stands for susamin
zusamin
zusamin which is german for
together
and that's all you have to do and in the
next few videos we'll do a bunch of
examples here so we can really figure
out whether to label something with
either an e or a z but i wanted to
expose you to the cis and trans naming
scheme because that's sometimes used for
simpler molecules where you only have
one functional group on each side but i
want you to realize that they're really
trying to make the same differentiation
they're really just trying to decide
whether the functional groups on one
side of a double bond and on the other
side of a double bond whether they're on
the same side cis or z or zusamine or on
different sides trans or e or etgen